نذكر بالخبر العاجل كما قلنا قبل قليل
وفاه اسطوره كره القدم العالميه
البرازيليه بيليه اذا ياتي ذلك بعد معاناه
طويله مع المرض تبعنا كلنا في الايام
الاخيره همم حجم ما وصل اليه تمكن المرض
منه وهو في سريره في ساعته وايامه الاخيره
وبطبيعه الحال الكل سيكون انظاره في
العالم على هذا الخبر الان خبر وفاه
نجم كره القدم البرازيليه اسطوره كره
القدم العالميه وبطبيعه الحال كل من
مسؤولين من من كبار قاعده اللعبه في
العالم من المسؤولين المعنيين بهذا
الموضوع همم
الهواه من
المحبين من متابعي الاسطوره يعني يتوا على
تشيعه بكلاما وايضا على ارض الواقع خاصه
على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي نحن سنتابع
هذا الخبر عندما تبدا ردود الافعال حوله